so Alan from reading your bio we see
that from an early age you knew you
wanted to be a filmmaker and that you
even went to film school I did can you
tell us about those years okay okay this
was in the i graduated from yale in 1965
I knew that I was going to come to Los
Angeles to go into the movie business
and to make movies I knew that from
junior high it actually happened when I
was watching the movie vertigo when I
was in junior high school i SAT through
it twice and at the end of it I said Tim
I'm going there I'm I want to do this
film school was a relatively new thing
in there in the middle 60s and I applied
for a Fulbright to go to Lee deck the
French film school and I was an
alternate for that but I came out to
California I didn't really know much
about LA I had been admitted to USC and
I didn't really even know that there was
a difference between UCLA and USC so I
went out to UCLA and they let me in I
mean one spot they let me in I that no
longer happens now it's very difficult
to get into those foam schools UCLA at
that time was in the middle of a
cultural revolution that had started in
Berkeley with the free speech movement
in lighting at 63 or 64 in the north end
of the campus of UCLA there was a gypsy
wagon where people would get food and
the fine art school was there the film
school was there the music school was
there and there was a scene of this
shift in my generations culture I worked
in the film library the UCLA theater
arts library I had a student job among
the other employees was Jim Morrison
this was the fall before the spring when
they exploded at the whiskey the doors
and I was making a student film and it
was too lavish and I ran out of money
and I needed a job and an executive at
Columbia Pictures had advertised through
UCLA that he was looking for an
assistant and I got the job so i arrived
at Columbia Pictures in 1967 I was 21
years old about to turn 22 I had been in
a film studio once and I was dropped
into really what was the last vestige
the dying gasp of the studio system
there was a man named MJ Frankovitch
Mike Frankovitch it was the head of the
studio he was the last the last tycoon
he was the last mogul and funny girl was
shooting and guess who's coming to
dinner was shooting and there were
contract actors and actresses and me and
you know and I think most of the studio
started hiring people from the film
school after that but I believe I was
the first and I was there for four years
I did very very well I advanced I moved
up the ladder it did not make me happy I
felt very away from the world of making
movies and I had an issue with
substances and so I walked away I walked
away and then began I did other things
but I also started getting movie deals
for screenplays I had over 30 movie
deals of screenplays that did not get
made as I say they're sleeping on the
shelves of certain studios and some of
them are still sleeping as some of them
may yet but may wake up you one never
knows what fate has in store for us
you